IT IS TIME FOR ODD PAIRINGS.
IN HONOR OF TONIGHT'S PANEL FROM
THE ODD COUPLE I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO KNOW GIVE ME AT MANY ODD
PAIRINGS AS YOU CAN.
ANYTHING FROM BATMAN AND OATS TO
RED WINE AND FISH.
WHO CARES.
WHATEVER IT IS, IT HAS TO BE TWO
THINGS THAT DON'T GO TOGETHER.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU 60-SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND GET WEIRD.
BEGIN.
TOM.
>> SIEGFRIED AND ROIDS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
YVETTE.
>> BUTCH CASSIDY AND THE JERRY
MAGUIRE KID.
>> CHRIS: POINT.
TOM LENNON.
>> RISOLI AND AISLES AND AISLES
OF DISCOUNT MATTRESSES.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
LINDSAY.
>> BILL COSBY AND THE CONSCIOUS
WOMAN.
>> OH, [BLEEP].
YES, POINTS! 100 PERCENT,
POINTS.
LINDSAY.
>> JOHN TRAVOLTA IN COMFORTABLE
MOMENTS.
>> CHRIS: YES, POINTS.
I'M JUST GOING TO PUT MY
HANDS ALL OVER YOUR BELLY.
(GRUNTING NOISES)
>> CHRIS: TOM.
>> MATTHEW PERRY AND THE GAY GUY
FROM RENO 911.